in this video we'll talk about drop D
test so let's understand what is drop T
Test drop T Test is a blood test which
can be used to determine a recent
incidence of a heart attack
detest is a blood test which can detect
heart attack or the risk of developing
angina pectoralis or severe chest pain
so in this test just blood is drawn from
the vein and a small test strip is used
to determine whether the individual is
drop T positive or negative
now in your sample after 12 hours of the
severe chest pain if you don't have drop
T then you are okay but if drop T is
detected in the blood that means you
have a
heart attack in last during the last
chest pain so overall property gives us
an idea about whether a heart attack has
taken place or not
so when property test is done it is done
when you have severe chest pain or you
might have a cardiac issue
so how property test is done
it's very simple the technician takes a
little bit amount of blood
and put it on a drop T test strip in the
top drop T test strip
the blood diffuses through our
capillary-like situation and there are
pre-loaded antibodies for the property
and pigeon
now from the property test
we can determine whether the test is
negative or positive so we have to wait
for about 30 minutes for this reaction
to occur
if two lines are appearing in the test
strip that means the test is positive
and if one line is appearing that means
the test is negative note that if no
line appears that means the test strip
is not actually actually functional
even if it is negative one line should
be always appearing and this is the
positive control
now Elisa based assays can also be used
to determine the property level in the
blood
so wait a minute what is drop T and
let's understand how drop T Test
actually works
so in our muscles there are actin
myosin and troponin
so in red you can see the troponin
molecules
so if you zoom in you would see there
are three type of troponins troponin i
troponin c and troponin T this troponin
T is actually abbreviated as trop t
be it skeletal muscle or be it cardiac
muscle
all these three troponins would be
present
but the troponins found in cardiac
muscle are bit different from the
skeletal muscle versions
so cardiac troponin tea is different
from the skeletal muscle ones
generally these kind of troponins are
supposed to be present
in the in the muscle and they are never
released in the blood
under circumstances of heart attack
cardiac troponin T is actually leaking
into the bloodstream
and our test actually detects this
particular cardiac troponin from the
blood so from the patient's blood using
an antigen antibody reaction cardiac
troponin is actually detected and that
is the sole biology behind the trop T
Test
so I hope
this video was useful if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe
you can get more notes and flashcard you
can visit my Facebook page support our
Channel using uh super thanks see you in
next video